[Musique]
nick donne vous êtes sans doute l'homme
le plus détesté l'amérique aujourd'hui
nick avez vous tué votre femme tout le
monde disait on répétait sans cesse le
mariage c'est une rude épreuve
tapant nick et moi comme vous le savez
tous son épouse amy holden a disparu il
ya quinze jours je n'ai rien à voir avec
sa disparition
je n'ai rien lâché et m'y attèle des
amis à qui nous pourrions parler non pas
vraiment vous ignorez si elle a des amis
vous ignorez ce qu'elle fait ces
journées vous ignorez même son groupe
sanguin
ils jouent les gentils garçons pour
qu'on pense que c'est un gentil garçon
vaut vous ne l'aimez vraiment pas je ne
fais rien de plus d'être courtois avec
tous ces gens qui bénévolement nous aide
à retrouver et me je vais m'entraîner à
croire qu'une marie même et je pourrais
me tromper
vous avez déjà vu ce type à lunettes l'
ennemi est le genre de femme qui attire
des admirateurs sans ravisseurs va
forcément la ramener j'espère que vous
avez une explication voulait résoudre sa
chasse aux trésors vous auriez vu cette
femme pas ici oui je me souviens d'elle
vous je vous connais je vous ai vu au
centre bénévoles je ferai mon aide que
voulait-elle elle voulait une arme
nous sommes tous terrifiés mais nous
sommes ensemble maintenant j'ai le
sentiment d'être une chose dont on
voudrait ce débarrasser le sentiment que
je pourrai star être le trait
caractéristique
sociopathe contre l'absence d'empathie
emi avait perdu beaucoup de sang mais
quelqu'un a tout nettoyé
pourquoi avoir nettoyé si on voulait
faire croire à un meurtre c'est parce
qu'ils ont trouvé mais à mon avis ça
doit pas être beau à bois j'avais fini
par réaliser que j'avais peur pour mon
propre mari je le buggy 2 comme si vous
déposez ce qu'il faut dire ce qu'il ne
faut pas dire que singes savants à saran
qui échappe à la peine de mort ne fera
de vous qu'une bouchée vous l'avez
agressé c'est pas assez bien pour toi
que c'est encore pire que ça absolument
pas je n'ai jamais touché
nous pensons que nick est impliquée dans
la disparition de notre vie sans cadavre
sans angle du crime
leur seul espoir serait pas davies avait
aucune nouvelle répondez moi franchement
comment était votre mariage vous êtes en
train de me demander si j'ai tué ma
femme l'homme de mes rêves qui partage
ma vie pour un étui dumas version disney
cet homme là pourrait me tuer ses
propres mots
[Musique]
me tuer vous connaissez l'expression les
bonnes réponses sont souvent les plus
simples
honnêtement pour moi ça n'a jamais été
une vérité